all right sluggies wow do we have a show
for you it gets really really wild
there's a lot of let's just say there's
a lot of physical contact on this one
and it gets
very sloppy in good ways
so tune in subscribe we are very excited
to deliver this episode to you oh we
have a new segment today trash tank see
what that is see what Annie thinks it is
don't even remember what it is
um you guys I've been doing stand up on
the road it is so much fun and I'm going
to be in Raleigh North Carolina coming
up Indianapolis Philadelphia San Diego
Austin Chicago sorry my Austin shows got
rescheduled it wasn't my fault I am
still sorry though they did that to me
too I know and so many more go to
astronice.com for tickets and check out
my clothing line at Sleepover by
esther.com and enjoy today it's crazy
all right you guys can see me in Naples
Florida Tampa Florida Springfield
Missouri New Westminster British
Columbia and Canada Washington DC
Richmond Virginia San Francisco
Dania Beach Florida Austin Texas Tempe
Arizona and many many more on my website
go to annieleterman.com those I cannot
wait it's been more fun than I can even
express
[Music]
what does it hurt your feelings when
your dude does not post you it's Shady
I totally disagree
well I want to hear your take on it
because I have a new mine's evolved I
used to okay because I
don't view Instagram as like
the place for that I really don't like
my Instagram is me me me like you know
how people are like look at her page
she's all selfies I'm like yeah that's
my page it's me self-promotion yeah so
I'm promoting myself I'm I'm social I'm
socializing with my friends and fans
that's such an old thought too like I
feel like that's like um the way that
like the New York comedy scene because I
feel like a lot of my friends in the New
York comedy scene their careers are not
doing well because they think they're
too cool for social media I'm not saying
all of them but like some of them where
it's like they're like that's just where
I go post my dates it's like no but this
is another place to entertain people
this is another Avenue to like tell
jokes and stuff but like what you're
saying I remember someone saying that to
me too being like wow you put a lot of
yourself on there and it's like have you
ever seen one of those sites one of
those people's sites there Instagram
sites well people's people's Instagrams
where it's like other it's like that's
weird that's voyeuristic that's like
creepier than anything else it's mine
it's everyone occasionally like me every
6 but see I actually I think your
Instagram should be whatever you want it
to be no
kalila should be only me and Annie I
know there's not really enough of us but
but yeah no I totally agree and I I feel
like actually social media I know
there's millions of takes and articles
about how it's so bad but I actually
have a very positive relationship with
it because I'm using it to socialize and
to express myself and to share but but I
know that's kind of a tangent but I I
love the way you share kind of like a
sloppy look you know the world sometimes
you go wow do you guys think it's Shady
to not post like what's your every
situation is different right because I
mean like obviously we're you guys are
public figures you have to be a lot more
protective of certain things about your
life I love that you think you're not a
public figure that's so funny it's so
cute she's getting a lot more famous
than us
well compared to Bobby at least like
he's a public figure I remember when I
first started dating him I used to be so
crushed like both flattered but crushed
every time he would post a picture of me
because they didn't just invited I
wasn't I was new to it all right so
people would just always go for what
what I looked like you know how shiny my
tits look like everything about it
that's so sad I missed the shiny tits
too oh it was shiny I really it was so
shiny I would have really been and that
was the one thing that Bobby just seemed
to always like post he always posted and
I remember he never used to pass
permission I would send him pictures of
me like in the bathroom and all of a
sudden it was on Instagram like you have
to take that down that was just for you
he was like yeah but you look so hot I
was like yeah but everything about it
like and this is when I couldn't not
read now I'm so good at not reading and
yeah it used to read I'm so good at not
reading too but not common just one
thing I'm able to read just books
wait that is crazy that you sent like
imagine sending your lover no no imagine
sending your lover like a sexy pic and
then you post it on Instagram no and
then all of a sudden you're getting like
before she saw it posted I'm sure she
started getting all these alerts like
follow follow
no but I think it's still up even if we
look back far enough on his thing I'll
tell you which picture it is I think
it's horrified it's darker if it's not
up and he went back and took it down
that's a darker situation wow he
listened to the Future go find it slugs
but I feel like okay so I used to think
it was a protection thing because I
never really posted Todd that much I
always wanted to like keep him like safe
I guess you don't want to like out them
or expose them to this world as you're
saying but then I thought about it and I
go I think I learned that from guys who
[__] cheat on their wives yes I think
I learned it from my friends who cheat
on their wives and that's the excuse
they use on the flip side the reason I
say it's situation for situation is
because a perfect example is there was
this guy I'm just gonna say his name I
don't give a [__] his name is Luis and
he's from Brazil there's so many of them
she acts like she's outing Louise
are you sure it wasn't Jose every other
photo was of him and his gorgeous chick
but every other message that I got
was from him trying to solicit sex for
me so it's like it doesn't it there is
no formula for there's no like way to
see yeah like they're all that insults
me too because I when guys do that it
makes me so like you just think I'm that
big yeah I had a guy that was like why
don't you walk me to my truck this
married guy or I'm like and we know him
I'm not gonna say who it is but um why
don't you give me a walk why don't you
get like you should walk me to my truck
I'm like so what I can blow you like
what who was it oh but it's just like
it's like why would I I love that we
have the same people that yes the same
ones
oh he came for me so hard and we know
his chick and like the thing that I
think is like at least a little bit
better
the fact Esther he's coming for you
don't worry that is it's just crazy now
that you washed your hair
on New Year's Eve while he was having
dinner with his family he was like what
are you doing tonight this year maybe
three years ago
he was like what are you doing tonight I
was like
left him on ready but he knows I hate
that I'm with my in-laws right now do
you want to go
um that is like he thinks you're gonna
be a partner in crime like for me I was
like single I'm like why would I like
it's not like we're deviants together
it's like you think because I was
thinking about like if we go to your
truck okay like let's say I was like in
which I was never in at all let's say I
was in I love it so wait we walked to my
car I finished my spot being very good
at comedy you not being good at comedy
and then that's cool by the way I don't
want like to be seen with you I know the
biggest clue you could ever give I'm
like so you're not good at comedy and
then you want me to walk you to your car
like so I let's say okay so I'm
literally like I I leave a sea of
adoring fans okay like I leave a sea of
like people being like can I take
pictures with you you're amazing where'd
you get your outfit it's Esther Club you
can get it on all right Sleepover by
Esther you can get it on our website and
Astron ice I'm like in the middle of
just like Joy you want me to stop like
what I've worked my ass off to do you
want me to stop doing that so I can walk
you you to a car that's more expensive
than the one I'm living in at that time
so then
then to what suck your dick like I'm not
coming in this situation like what is
this where's my orgasm in this scenario
there's no like it wasn't what are you
gonna bang me doggy style while the the
door guys look [__] Christopher
Columbus me no what is the incentive but
that's what I'm saying I'm like what
would I get out of this did I get to
suck your unfunny dick like I'm good I'm
good and this person's nice enough do
you know what I mean but it's like dude
how delusional I have seen this happen
to you multiple times where these I'm a
hoe in a different way than I'm a hoe I
know you mistake my hoe you misread my
type of hoe we come you don't that's the
kind of who I am yeah same dude it's
crazy like it's just why would like the
fact that they think we would like enjoy
their jizz so much it's like
I know I'm just so traumatized by even
when you say his name just like years of
and I I have the I still have the
receipts and one day I'm gonna just
submit it to dumois one day and they're
gonna do that baby today I'm gonna go
who is this they're gonna go you're
actually more of a public figure
that is she's not wrong that's not a
joke it's uh it's just really also very
interesting to hear people pronounce
Dumont because I never do my ex
is silent that's weird
um I it is I here's why I'm I like this
conversation so much because you guys
are talking about a person who is the
perfect example of a guy who if he walks
into the room he does not see me well
you're very short no it's not that it's
like there are guys that like only see
the women they want to [__] and then the
other women are just like I feel like
you come right up to his penis you could
just do like a standing [__] you
should be very attracted to you sure no
bending no squats they don't see me
oh they just see you ladies but you know
he stopped seeing me when my tits came
off are you seeing my shiny yes well
that's I don't think he has a type
because my tits were never put on and
they're still in the freezer and I
listen I don't mind like like back in
the day I kind of liked flirting with
these guys it was fun to kind of like be
in that sort of like Comedy Store like
yeah silly like what do you wear what
shoes you're whatever and it's like but
now it's just like I'm so [__] over
it yeah and it's just because it was
abused do you know why I think Bobby is
one of the hottest men I'll ever know is
because you have this uh problem with
your eyes uh I showed him all of these
text messages and DMS on Twitter and did
you hold the D because there was a dick
in it the DMS the DM and not even
slightly
perturbed he was just like oh yeah like
he's a [__] like so unbothered and
so like trusting of the situation where
he was like oh yeah like he could never
have you like that's how sure he was
that's that is the secret to being hot
as a guy is being so confident that you
you're just like whatever yeah it has to
be the right like measurement of it
though because if they just don't care
at all but Bobby knows that he can trust
you he knows you're not gonna [__] do
yeah but he also knows that that type of
man is not so not for me at all I know
and it's like
oh they're just so sloppy it's like
don't send me a peach
he's got me a peach peach I had the same
piece you [__] hack like me I'm
quality top quality here okay I would
just like to go on the record and say a
man has never sent me a peach
but I don't know and I don't know if I'm
proud or sad it's really it's like
you have to choose what you want okay
because I think you are like you're a
hot person that hides hotness and you
don't like they think we're like ready
like they think we're like ready to drop
Chinese it's like a sad so he I think
he's just too he's I'm gonna go with the
narrative that he's just too dumb to see
how beautiful he's intimidated by you
yeah
no he literally thinks we would we would
be like please let's gag on your [__]
like he like it's that's the sad part
well he looks at us like we would do it
what yeah I'm the car thing is
interesting like what could you do in a
car that would actually be worth it for
us
unless on all fours drive me to my
boyfriend to a hotter guy
drive me to a hotter guy is the best
answer yeah unless I'm on all fours and
my [__] is sticking out the window and
he's eating me out from the outside
wait you know what I like about this I'm
imagining it's like an old truck and you
have your [__] backed up to that that
little like crevice window they have
yeah and that's the window that opens
they just open that little triangle side
window that they have on the old truck
if this person had said this at The
Comedy Store parking lot how about you
just stick your [__] out my window and
I'm just gonna stand here and and eat it
in front of everyone I would have been
like yeah okay
that sounds like you can see out the
window sounds like it's gonna get caught
in the door though oh no you slammed it
I can't imagine like saying to a guy
well no I've said some fun things you
guys but we were like together I would
have liked to have been like sure I'll
walk you to your car let's get in your
car okay okay now we're in your car okay
play with my hair okay we braid my hair
pet me like rub me like was he was he
doing that to your long pubes
just like try to make him do no you'd be
like get me candy
do you have milkshakes in here
what if you what if a guy hit on you and
then like he took you to his car and it
turns out that he was on that show that
exhibit used to do I'll Pimp My Ride and
there were like high heels in the back
and stuff remember how it would always
feel a shoe store
I dated a guy
um same guy who like freaked out when a
cockroach um the Mexico cockroach story
but I dated a guy who hated his ex so
much because she cheated on him with
exhibits
his ride
I know it is like would you rather be
cheated on by like a rando a guy or a
famous person what would hurt you the
most right now who would Dave have to be
secretly having a clandestine
relationship with donut I was just gonna
say donut which is happening and I'm
actually fine with it donut is such a
gift from the lord it's so crazy she's
so Angelic she's so [__] she's also
[__] like she flirts with Carlos a lot
I felt like barking up the wrong tree
um Carlos is marking that down I like
that do you mark down every time someone
makes fun of you
wait I have a segment I have a segment
to put you guys okay I hope it's
recurring is this segment um pitching a
segment yes it's time to talk about what
is a segment okay so I have a game it's
called trash tank okay so it's the one
we let you eat us out
it's like Shark Tank
what what if you started doing that to
guys at the company yes I'm going to
welcome me to my camera
[Laughter]
yeah you would be such a good creep
because they do want to [__] you this is
the thing Esther you're just like you're
a secret because they can't you look
young so you out another part of them if
they were to just like blatantly hit on
you I'm 33 though but it's the yeah it
okay trash tape sorry hear me out
it's like shark tank but we pitch each
other I today I'm pitching a business
idea that I think really fits well in
the universe of trash Tuesday okay it's
like a strip club
except to wear naked in your clothes
damn it it's like a strip club but
the dancers don't get naked you just
wear like a cute bra maybe a thong and
we just sexy dance to like 70s cool
music that I feel like old guys like and
so it's just like a place to go where
you can see women dancing to cool 70s
music
an old man are watching well anyone can
go can I can I add add to this business
it's just ex-boyfriends it's only
ex-boyfriends
is something preventing you from
achieving your goals plenty of things my
anxiety my seasonal depression I'm
having sleep problems now again wow I
didn't expect that money problems wow
you guys okay
Master's been using better help more
than us and now his needs less help you
guys we want you to check out
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist and you can connect in a safe
and private online environment it's so
convenient and all without ever having
to sit in an uncomfortable waiting room
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed which is such a big deal because
sometimes it's just not a match yeah and
then you feel guilty for leaving your
therapist and you know what I feel like
I feel like we've kind of been in this
era of like talk about your mental
health issues talk about them and that's
great and we've done that and now it's
about taking care of your mental health
and I think it's really I think this
year should be the year we all really
take steps to yeah because make our
lives better we I wanna I need everyone
in my life to deal with their [__] with
their therapist like on their own time
so that you can come to me and be your
best self and I want to offer that to
everyone in my life too like I want to
come to you with my best foot forward
and I can do that because I use better
help and it really is happening isn't it
Esther I really it is wild we have
worked on ourselves we at trash Tuesday
want you to start living a happier life
today and as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhealth.com trash
Tuesday join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help
help.com trash Tuesday I I will say this
I am so happy
that the pandemic is sort of
opening back up we can go out and stuff
and go but one thing I really hate is I
don't like going and shopping I hate
waiting in line I hate picking
everything out and that is why I
absolutely love Stitch fix freestyle
well Stitch fix freestyle is a shop that
is built just for you and for me
personally online shopping in general
can be very daunting I never know things
are going to fit returns are so annoying
I just found out that I'm on a no
returns list for one of my favorite
stores and is that your parents house
um but this season I'm saying screw it
I'm letting Stitch fix do all the work
for me whether you're looking for a
brand you love or or to try a new one at
Stitch fix freestyle you can shop over a
thousand Brands and styles personalized
to your size and fit you just take a
test
um
with styles for workouts to work wear
for lounging around the house or for a
night out on the town Stitch fix
freestyle has clothes for any occasion
and it's amazing because there's no
subscription required and they offer
free shipping returns and exchanges you
guys can get started today by filling
out your style quiz at stitchfix.com
Tuesday that's stitchfix.com Tuesday to
try Stitch fix freestyle at
stitchfix.com Tuesday
because when I went to Australia they
had 28 and over only clubs where anyone
younger could not go 20 28. so we should
have an age range yes so if it's a 70s
place and it's a Swanky thing for older
gentlemen
um I think that it should be
35 and over only or 40 and over only for
the guests for the guests yeah it should
be a very specific age range I like that
like 35 to 55. I like that a lot I would
almost say like Todd can't come you can
drop me off just to wait outside Todd
can't come for 15 years
Todd doesn't wait till I'm literally
dying of old age to get him to the club
when can I see my girl dance so I asked
him last night if he wanted I was like
do you ever want to go to like a strip
club or anything he's like no he's like
I have my bow I was like do you want me
to learn how to sexy dance he goes no
well you're going to at this that's so
funny that my boyfriend is just I feel
like that's common
I feel like guys are just like I mean
it's so embarrassing to do a sexy dance
to a guy that doesn't want a sex video
my worst fear do you think Dave would
react well to you sexy dancing yeah yeah
Bobby would not to you sexy dancing or
to me sexy dancing nobody else
wait but you know what I feel like Dave
would be suspicious at first that's what
I like about Dave he's always like what
are you up to again it's like his first
reaction that is so true is this for me
or for you yes
what are you doing this business idea is
for me obviously how do you feel about
the age range I love serving alcohol
yes is it a full service bar it can be
okay
yeah no okay they we have it's weed we
searched
that's very 70s we sell edible yeah it's
very it's all 70s themed and it's the
the three of us have to just and it's
not hard dancing I'm talking like just
you know slow body rolls and you're just
kind of like and maybe we have mirrors
what I can do so we can get what I can
exactly so I'm allowed to be a part of
it and we can you you know you can crawl
and lay on the stage and act like a
kitten like it's very it's whatever you
want it to be wow you're really trying
to get try to [__] you crawl it again
no I was waving away my smoke oh he was
like this I was like oh he's auditioning
for the club I think you're on to
something yeah I think that if I imagine
what my dad would have loved yeah
um there are certain elements that I
think that
my dad was also born in 1924. keep that
in mind wait first I can't I'm putting a
number on it it's really crazy makes it
really crazy telling us the year makes
him the oldest man I've ever imagined
existed okay so next year my dad would
have been a hundred oh we'll be a
hundred we have to celebrate it my dad's
daddy white instead of Betty White yes
Oh Daddy Wayne we have to celebrate that
so you have no idea I think that's like
the only reason I like I'm obsessed
that's her dad is so old but you know
what we should do you know what we
should do we should in honor of your dad
find a really old guy strip club I just
like we were talking about that anyway
when I think what my dad would like
I gotta go to the Philippines that
sounds fun there
so I'm gonna reframe that and it's not I
don't think about my father when I think
about your new business venture okay I'm
gonna go ahead and say that I think
um about my father's friends when what
they would like
they also were all born in 1924. the
fact that the age range is now 99 to
100. so it makes it so much better
[Laughter]
I just feel like for some reason I feel
like this idea this club where we get to
dance sexy in front of mirrors and men
get to go whoever wants to go I feel
like everyone's happy right because like
we get to like show off but we're not
naked and there's no you know there's
nothing more to it and then the guys are
happy because they can relax and listen
to music they like
I that's not why they're going they're
not going for the music they're relaxing
are you sure because I have a really
good playlist I have an idea 70s I like
that but I have an idea what if we make
it's just for lesbians okay okay and
then I mean guys I mean but they have to
be they're like on the outside there's
like a a inner concentric Circle outer
concentric and they're behind like
plexiglass like they can't they can just
yeah
see what the girls are into yeah I like
that because they don't get front row
wait last night okay so I have this bit
where I talk about role play and I and I
do some crowd work with it where like I
ask if people have done role play and I
ask them what they've done and last
night someone said gynecologist and I I
was like that is my worst nightmare and
then they go oh but we're lesbians and I
was like I get it for the reason that
lesbian gynecologists changed it I have
the duck bill from when we were
nurses I stole the duck bill from that
episode so I actually have it and Todd
was chasing me around with it as a joke
but I was like maybe we could see what's
up we came up with a new um Kink the
other or a little while ago what you're
your dad me and my lover
um so the new role play
um in our household is I'm a lesbian
he's gay we're really uninterested in
each other
like so and we're in college we have no
interest in each other at all but we're
just like [__] we haven't gotten laid so
we have really lazy like
uninvolved like disengaged sex so I was
like I guess I'm doing this you're like
I'm not gonna come and we're both saying
I'm not gonna come I'm not going to come
like me neither but we're like so
desperate so we just that is amazing do
you like to be tied up
um is that scary it scares me I know
that's why I think I want to do it it's
like karaoke because I just don't trust
Bobby with his um not game and also
Bobby like would just like leave he
hears like a little alert yeah to go
play [__] whatever game he plays if
we ever don't hear from kalila for a few
days she hasn't shot to the podcast
no Bobby needs her to like walk the dogs
and stuff he would untie her real fast
do you get hungry feed me
he'd honestly call me and he'd be like
where are you I forget that he I was
stuck somewhere like I know he would
miss you that's the thing yeah he would
be like sad that you're not with him but
also the reason you're not well I was
thinking about it because
I like I feel like I still have like a
fear of pleasure a little bit so I kind
of go in like do you guys like cover
yourself up when you come yes so I I
feel like I want to try I don't know if
it's possible to like be like this is
like maybe I need to get tired well this
is why if I masturbate I come so quickly
is because no one's looking at me and if
somebody is pleasuring me and they're
looking right at me all times look
through the window
so what I'll say is you know like don't
take this the wrong way but then I'll
cover my face with a pillow yes so I'm
just eating I know why but why do we
have to smother ourselves why do I have
to worry about the sounds I'm making you
know the gaze into his eyes because he's
looking at me for a reaction I know he's
getting off but I really just don't want
the pressure of looking pretty so I just
shove a pillow in my face and I'm like
it's I don't know it's about like how I
look it's literally like my instinct is
to just like cover up I don't know I
think it's it's like how it's like a
cultural thing like I feel like the
generations below us won't be like that
but I do feel like because I I feel like
all women like in our age range like
feel that well they get to learn from
Euphoria
here's the thing too that my dad watches
by the way oh but to know that my dad's
favorite shows Euphoria is so upsetting
I love that for him
not for you but what is the show for
your dad no I know it's like you're it's
too old for kids in high school and then
it's too young for grown-ups it's so
triggering when you find out your
parents are watching something like that
like I remember I knew my parents loved
True Blood and then I booked a True
Blood commercial and I so I like what
was it I like for the D this is how can
we find it yeah this is like how much
the industry has changed since I've been
in it I was in a commercial selling DVDs
for True Blood on your little hands
Wiggles are those the handsomething
American Girl dolls and then so I booked
the commercial so I was like oh I'm
gonna watch I'll watch some of the
episodes and the show ended up being so
good I remember I watched like three
seasons in a weekend and there was so
much sex and like just crazy [__] I'm
like this is what my parents this is a
show my parents watching now and they
sit next to each other yeah and your
dad's commenting your dad's not just
watching your dad has like a whole
thought process behind it about I wonder
so who does your dad watch Euphoria with
the local teams he'll like he'll watch
it like my mom will go to sleep and then
he'll watch it and it's like he's not
jerking off because let's be real his
dick hasn't worked for years but
he's always like my rubber ducky and
like that it's so weird that you want to
just bring your penis up but um here we
go True Blood the blood for the holidays
featuring Esther povitzki is this it
what's this honey okay Grandma so it's
this show about this crazy town in
Louisiana that is filled with sex-crazed
vampires and they all want sookie's
blood who's blood Sookie she's a
waitress and a fairy and a mind reader
some people call her Fang banger but
those people are religious freaks no
offense her best friend Tara lives with
the she demon who sometimes makes Tara's
eyes go all black and the whole town has
a huge orgy Merry Christmas Grandma I
love you so much
laughs
that's actually cute oh my God were you
cast as a 12 year old dude you were
obviously but about 10 years younger
than you are in that isn't that crazy
can you imagine seeing a commercial for
DVDs right now but what's funny too is
your the commercial is the reality of
the world you were living in other but
you're it was the grandmother it was
like your family telling you about the
orgies
we used to watch Sex in the City
together meet my parents oh I have
horrible memories of them watching it
and me just walking upstairs in the
hallway and being like what did I just
hear him like that she squirted is that
it how did you handle watching it with
them you just sit quietly
um you just kind of like stay forward
it's a it's more of like a squaring off
with the television you just stay it's a
shoulder exercise it's a shoulder
exercise and you're kegling which is
awkward but you do have to have
everything has to be tight your core
and you just watch it but I told you
guys that I saw a Requiem for a Dream
with my dad right yeah yeah that was
really
I remember watching The L Word with my
mom
um we would just sit a certain we'd sit
further apart from each other I think
yes to not you know we wouldn't feel the
steam off each other's [__] yeah you
don't wanna you don't wanna any sort of
like you don't want to smell the stew
you know yeah
so yeah I don't want these are the women
I met in Hollywood and said let's do a
show with them and honestly you're doing
great look at you're doing great now
you're welcome
I want to ask you guys a question about
um something do we
really make sex sounds because we feel
them or are we programmed to make them
such a good question I would say I was I
would say my 20s were like the 1920s it
was like a silent film and Kyle's dad
was there yeah and Lila's dad was
stroken cooking some stew yeah I was
like dead silent and that is actually
louder than noise if you're silent
during sex yes it's like a deafening
loud but I was so insecure you know just
like
just only thinking about the guy's
experience and not my own
um now noises come out that are I've had
to check myself recently because I'm
like why am I making these sounds am I
really just doing it because I know that
you know it's a way to validate his
experience because when I'm really close
to coming truthfully I don't make any
sounds I'm so hyper focused on my own
that I'm like there are no sounds coming
out of me so I'm like I think that so
much of my upbringing has to do with
validating the man's experience that's
wild it's so when you think back on it
isn't it crazy yes yes I know that I
just feel like health class could be so
much better like I don't need to know
how boners work I need to know like you
went well first of all you went to a bad
school so yes they showed me how voters
work
it's very hands-on experience
was method acting it was also our method
action James Franco
yes I wish
with vo and dreads daughter
unfortunately James Franco shot Annie
sex that is absolutely
that's something that's on a t-shirt for
me his admission recently where he's
like so I banged a couple of my students
yeah I saw that what can you do uh he
booked a couple of them I feel like oh
wait last night I think I know okay so I
was saying when I came in we weren't
recording yet I was saying that I feel I
felt like I had like an an out of
the ordinary rough set last night
on stage not after I felt like I was
getting [__] punched donkey punched
my tongue no but I I and you know what I
realize it is it's
um Brad Pitt was there he wasn't in the
audience but I was afraid he was gonna
walk in and so I was very Brad Pitt was
there Brad Pitt was at The Comedy Spot
Santa's
thing so he didn't see any of our sets
[Music]
was it that good it was Brad Pitt see it
good last night
you can't see me anytime can I just tell
you the audience was great I I tipped
the audience into a weird place you know
when I got there it was fire so I was
like I bet you everyone had a great set
and I went on like Brad Pitt's like I
just under under the undertone of
everything was like Brad Pitt's here
like how did you know that because the
um when I pulled up there was like
Security Guys and I was like who is that
that was I I always know to ask when
they're suspicious looking thank you
because now I know never asked because
that would have I would have bombed I
was like and I didn't get to meet him or
anything he was gone by the time I was
there I walked him
um no he didn't see it but it was like I
don't know just the idea that he could
walk in just made me so nervous and then
I was thinking what would my pitch be
when I met Brad Pitt because I've met
celebrities before and I and they're
never like I know the pitch good I have
an idea but Todd and I were trying to
like go through what the move would be
because there is a way but he's a
different level of famous like I met
Dylan and Matt Dillon was my first like
famous person I was chatting with
because I was his waitress this was my
move to him and this is what I would
maybe do to to Brad Pitt like at some
point I would go like
is it so it's weird to be Brad Pitt
right everyone's like weird around you I
would start asking like questions about
like the existential crisis that being a
huge celebrity is
people put a lot on you people like Matt
Dylan I was like you've been famous
since you were like since I was 14 he
was like eating his eggs you guys he
like loved telling me about it I just
realized something Brad Pitt what he's
like 50. he's like this is our chance to
invite him to our club no Brad Pitt well
my pitch was can I walk you to your
truck
a peach is that enough how lazy too can
you put out like a little bit of A
Better Effort to just sending us a
[__] Peach we know Brad Pitt okay we
don't Barbara was in the same building
as this last night okay we know him I
can't believe that that explains why
security was not letting me in one of
the rooms because something I did I
don't know tell me if this is douchey or
not so I was like Aziz I'm sorry I was
in the other room and I was peeking in
and this door guy is he taller or
shorter than you I don't I'm sure he's
taller and joke landed let's go
a lot of greens my favorite well before
they even became our sponsor I remember
you were telling me about athletic
greens and you got me hooked on them I
cannot believe that they're our sponsor
now and it's one of those things where
it's like I don't have to feel bad when
I'm not eating my vegetables that day
I'm like look guys in five minutes a
little stir and some cold water
I have it all eating a salad is a chore
it is it's just like Ugh what is in this
stuff Esther with one delicious scoop of
athletic greens you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals Whole Foods
Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging all the things
I am a person who's tried every powder
on the planet because I've lived in La
for 10. I think I've tried more powders
than you probably
this is the one that delivers on its
promise you guys it's lifestyle friendly
too so whether you eat keto paleo vegan
dairy free or gluten-free it contains
less than one gram of sugar no GMOs No
nasty chemicals or artificial anything
while still tasting good and it supports
better sleep quality and Recovery right
now it's time to reclaim your health and
arm your immune system with convenient
daily nutrition especially heading into
the flu and cold season it's just one
scoop in a cup of water every day that's
it no need for a million different pills
and supplements to look out for your
health to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com Tuesday
again that's athleticgreens.com Tuesday
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
Insurance oh my God you guys it's so
good this next sponsor I actually tried
it last year at a restaurant and I was
like that is the best breakfast burrito
I've ever had and I it was vegan and it
was made with our sponsor just egg just
egg is a cholesterol-free plant-based
egg that will give you the most decadent
quiches of your life the fluffiest
scrambles and the easiest egg sandwiches
of all time
it has about the same protein as a
chicken egg and less saturated fat plus
just egg is packed with cholesterol
lowering polyunsaturated fat chicken
eggs wish they were this healthy my
parents have been plant-based for like
four years and I sent them just egg and
it blew their minds I feel like I always
hear them my mom talking about new ways
she's making it she's making breakfast
wraps she's making omelets it's so good
let's fly her out here to make us some
just eggs I want your mom to be working
for me dude same
happy New Year everyone may be filled
with just egg just egg really good eggs
and so I was peeking in and the dork I
was like oh you need tickets for do you
have tickets for the show and I was like
no and he's like then you need to go
back to your showroom and I just like
grabbed his hand and was like hi I'm
Esther I'm a comedian here and I walked
away and I'm like is that douchey of me
but I was so I've been going to The
Comedy Store for 13 years
the same room as Brad Pitt if he's there
we are we're paid that's not his home
that's your home he's visiting their
guests in our house when people try to
give me [__] I go you can go read listen
I'm not going to answer you can just go
read my name on the wall That's the
answer it's not douchey at all okay yeah
that person is a complete guest in your
home also that door man yeah should no
like that's the worse
it's so funny the comp no one at The
Comedy Store knows who I am
they just don't see it I think again
it's really a nice thing you're solving
all my problems you've been thinking
about it all wrong
[Laughter]
I literally don't see you until they
trip
you guys the fans have spoken and they
have last week we asked can I just say
I'm gonna reject it already Okay go
ahead I don't know what it is
um so last week we asked our fans to
tell us what life skill we should pick
up for this year for 2022. okay and we
have answers okay Annie do you want me
to read yours yes please you know I
can't okay is that number one learn to
read Annie in 2022
our fans would like you to learn
woodworking okay as a possibility okay
so here are the options woodworking
one day of a silent Retreat it's like
you're setting me up for failure here
learning to learn a new language learn
CPR how to bake ooh ax throwing I think
you could be really good I would like to
do all of these uh-oh
um how to rap and make a track I feel
like you already know how to do that or
make it in a truck
how did deep sea dive learn the
structure of her local government
no and let me see how to budget with a
spreadsheet no boring okay
ax Sterling I feel like ax throwing but
that seems like you know I think sort of
a hack you can do that like at the mall
it's one of them says learn the
structure of local government I think
you should run for local government yeah
just a one-up it the only way I'm doing
it is if I run I
um yeah Esther I want you to just run
oh my God my personal trainer told me
that I don't know how to run I thought
that that was like my whole life that
that was people making fun of me but
there's a thing you can't some people
can't run no no no no your personal
trainer I'm suing your personal trainer
they've got to stop telling you that
you're special you're not special you're
a normal person that needs to build up
muscles and learn things you can learn
to run right
okay this is good we're having her come
here no because it's like who you need
to learn you're less special than you
are you're special in a like in a
in a way like your spirit is special
your body is normal you're just short
you don't have like different neck
muscles than us you don't have different
ability to learn to run this is really
good for your I know what you're doing
you're reprogramming my subconscious
beliefs you're trying to tell me that
I'm okay
I this one's actually just the truth
this isn't I'm not there's no uh
ulterior motive no but it is like you if
you think you run weird you will run
weird but you do run weird but you can
learn but you go to the shoe store and
they help you that's true okay wait what
life skill
of these Annie what do you think you're
gonna take to I think the idea of
woodworking fascinating that kind of
sounds cool I like that idea woodworking
sounds cool splinters I would like to
learn I would like to learn to sing or
dance really is like really it's like
scary for me and I feel like with all
the work I've done in myself I've
learned that
that fear Blocks Your like spirit and
like everything that's like so there's
something there for me because I'm
fearful I need to go through it is that
what we choose then I think it's dancing
this year then dancing or singing I want
to do woodworking too but that's like
something I would want to do
I feel like you'd be really good at
dancing really I mean because you were a
go-go dancer like you I was so drunk I
literally fell off the podium it was
like I was crying all the time my thing
was up on my hitting me in the face but
the fact that you were already a paid
dancer like you already have you're
already ahead of the game and you
already have a mentor yeah I know you
can you did teach me the the [__] dance
last summer and I was kind of able to
make a jiggle I just can't I have to
release the like my lower back region
I'm unable to release it's very tight
but you will be yes the thing with that
I always say with dance it's like
it's just about practice but you your
neck doesn't have the muscles and you
can't run your personal trainer's evil
is that what we choose then for Annie I
I think dance is it so by the end of the
year will you show us a dance routine
yeah by the end we have a whole year to
do this yeah it's your skill I want to
learn to sing too I want to take singing
lessons but George has to pay
them
Power by George I wonder you're out of
his son's college fund
um Esther these are your options okay
how to change a tire no how to leave a
driveway okay [__] you I've been with
Esther when she's begrudgingly not
changed a tire twice remember when
you're like
were you there the night it was so sad
that it was like it was the night the
last night I saw Brody in my car I was
in the car with you yeah like when it's
I actually stepped into it in the Tarts
yeah we changed it and you didn't know
some guy but I had to remind you
remember that they were helping you a
group of guys at The Comedy Store helped
put the spare on it was really nice not
quite fast enough for you though if I
recall oh yeah I was really stressed I
forgot why I was stressed no I was
stressed I don't remember why but it's
like that because that was the last
night that we all saw Brody and I was
really upset because I remember he
walked past while I was dealing with the
tire and so I always think like I didn't
say hi you know yeah anyway no I talked
to him don't worry it wasn't better
talking to him because he was literally
like when I talked to him he literally
was like my meds aren't working and I
was like bro you're gonna get I mean he
literally just said all the things
there's nothing you could do but cool
I'm glad you brought this up because I
notice you have some new Broad and Ester
shirts that are really yeah tell me
about that yes I have brodermester
shirts I actually think they're they're
not available right now so I feel bad
talking about them but I did decide to
do like a limited edition because I used
to host a podcast with the comedian
Brodie Stevens who passed away two three
years ago February 2019.
um
and she's like I know the date and I
just can't do the math uh
and I I just thought it was I just was
like I want to do like fake merch for
our old podcast and then do the send the
proceeds like to I picked a charity
crisis text line I'm getting
uncomfortable I'm getting nervous it's
good I'm fine I'm glad you're doing it
though because I'm fine you guys had
such a cute like great relationship you
were so funny together you were so funny
on his TV show too it was like oh thanks
yeah so I was gonna be sweet to see that
but yeah they said Broad and Esther and
then it said you can take her outside
that's fine I remember going through
your makeup bag when you lived in your
car and it your car your all your makeup
you kept it in a plastic grocery bag and
I
don't you can put me in a house
big TV but I got a Zoomies back I'm
preparing his headband because I know um
later on in this episode we're doing a
hickey Challenge and I remember what
Annie said last week about boys and
headbands so oh she's getting me horny
yeah I need I need to get my Ani horny I
might need a chaser after Esther's neck
okay so Annie has chosen dancing Esther
um music and woodworking okay and these
ones I'll name you a couple other ones
um gardening how to crochet my mom buy
one bougie item for yourself
she's good at that now
um what about learn about plant medicine
and herbs what about Ayahuasca do
Ayahuasca no I think you should change a
flat tire that's [__] to honor Broody
and that's a life skill that will help
you so mean what about what what about
running
I want to run I'll be a runner how do
you how do we prove that at the end of
the year you've learned to run my
trainer no we don't no she's
untrustworthy no no she's hard as [__] I
mean you would like her actually I swear
I swear is this the same one that cut
down your sessions to 20 minutes because
30 minutes yes
but that was because there was no other
way she gives into pressure that's not a
good thing no no I think that if you
guys saw my met my trainer you would she
gets it she laughs at me she's like
you're so dramatic
like I I want you guys to meet my
trainer that's like now on my oh my God
we should have our trainers on
yours is just Peloton I really want mine
to be I want to learn how to run like a
real Runner okay is that okay okay so
then I think the angle is a marathon oh
[__] how about a 5K
I'll do it with you I'll do it with you
okay oh my God kalila's gonna do it a
couple times she'll come back she'll
give us Gatorade we'll be like oh you
finished that I promise you I might be
worse at running than Esther I don't
look as bad running but I'm not very
good at it at least she looks hot when
she does a [__] if you want to go if
you want to get a peach DM to you [__]
you better learn how to look hot when
you run I still look hot running but I'm
very slow and I actually don't enjoy it
at all like when people are like that
runner's high I never get it I've never
gotten in my life I don't care if I'm
you know 30 minutes in I just I never
feel it I've never gotten that far like
I always quit within 10 minutes okay so
it's just not funny I think running is
perfect Esther great I think a 5k okay
I think I can do it my dad was a runner
I kind of know the how disappointing for
him
this is
do you guys have like a wheelchair ramp
at your house for you oh my God
what are my options all right kalila we
got Plumbing I would love it
if you knew Plumbing I would go down on
stand-up comedy we have to do the ones
we're afraid of the most I do not know
how to start a fire using sticks but I
do know sort of how to do a bow drill
don't let it freeze my stand-up comedy
there stand up comedy let's do stand-up
comedy but can we also learn to make
fires in case I'm on Survivor let's just
buy a fire starter human being can make
a fire if we have to they we all have
done it when we were cavemen you rub
this you'd be surprised how hard it is
in humid weather I'm no no you know what
okay no you're right and I like your
energy and you know what we're gonna do
that next time starting a fire you're
gonna show us how caveman you are [__]
I can't wait
no you're right I'm with you I suppose I
will give you one but you could start a
fire I will give you
five thousand dollars if on the show you
you can show us the bow drill technique
and start a fire the bow drill technique
okay I'll look into that and get back to
you let's have a fire starting
competition fine can we have a Survivor
oh guys I'm getting so excited what's my
skill though Stand Up become a hurricane
minister no it's stand up wait I've
already tried stand-ups it doesn't
matter with us for our show for our
ratings not for Bobby's life okay
you guys would want to be associated
with an open Miker yes honey you hate
open mikers
I [__] so many of them though so it's
a weird relationship it's an equal it
balances out I think you should have to
do like three minute
of material
at The Comedy Store at the store where
are you on stage
not a chance what we'll do is flappers
downstairs Open Mic that's it no no no
we're not taking it no I think you know
you don't get to you don't get to hide
it Flappers it'll be a night where me
and Annie are up at The Comedy Store
back to back I'll do I'll do 10 minutes
she'll do 10 minutes and then we'll all
come out and we'll be together no no no
I do I'm a three minute low expectation
host I introduce you I cannot be
somewhere in the mix in the middle I
cannot go after you it's got to be like
I I I suck and then you guys come you're
the big surprise guys I'm gonna end up
singing on stage do you know how much
worse that is than anything you can
imagine happening wait are we doing all
of these life skills on stage Esther has
to run on
we put it bring a treadmill on
okay um I veto that decision can we and
just one other one maybe fine
but we're putting a pin in that for
later okay I have a gun what if we held
her at gunpoint
how to make pasta what the [__] I'm a
pasta Queen
all right maybe stand up three minutes
three minutes
three minutes is that what you said yeah
three minutes okay
you guys wanna this you wanna be so
embarrassed of me you wanna
you're going to want to not associate
with me I'm going to be an open Miker
you're going to get what you want
you're gonna be like oh my God we don't
know her what if she like loves doing
comedy and she's better than us
sell everything out Bobby has done this
to me and it did not work out I hated it
I was not good at it we don't care if
you like it or good at it okay all right
but you know what I think it's for you
to overcome that fear
to go through the field okay got it got
it challenge accepted okay three minutes
and you have to run
that's so annoying what's something that
you don't really get embarrassed though
no you get fake embarrassed and it
always works and I always believe Esther
can really you can like get an audience
to really feel for you in a way that
I've never seen anyone really
when used this used to kill me when I
would like lunge at you and you would
pretend to be hurt and people would be
like you're hurting I'm like this is a
bit and she's just a better actor
she's just a main actress
oh I'm like oh I'm gonna kill you now
I'm Really Gonna Hurt You
okay here are the rules for our 2022
hickey challenge okay okay so we are
judging each other on darkness and shape
and it's from a scale of one to ten
um an example an eight for darkness and
a nine for shape is a score of Seventeen
the darker the better
the rounder the better I think the
bigger the better these rules suck
Carlos based on Wiki how Okay
on Wikipedia
would you do it on her inner thigh what
if we saw like a thing I'll do this I'll
do my hickey anywhere the only thing is
you're gonna hurt me
you're both gonna hurt me because you're
gonna be trying to make it dark it's
only for 30 seconds it won't kill you
highest score wins a prize I don't think
rounder is better I think bigger is
better okay what do you guys think I
think no one surprised you thought
bigger is better
I agree like I I don't want to be so
focused on shape but you know what it
might be until you see them and you
might just be like that one just looks
beautiful
so maybe it's just which one is visually
it's like um like an MMA like basically
it's like so gross out I have to touch
my mouth you're guys nasty I took a bath
in my own I did shower today but I I
feel like I'll taste like lotion I also
do have a pimple there so be careful
why can't like right here is a good
place no
it's it need a very fast there's like my
[__] is really clean okay Annie here
clylla down here who's starting
um Carlos you're gonna have to so each
of us are doing it on each of us each of
us leaves with two hickeys each okay
I'm brave you guys want to suck on my
neck it's ready it's very moisturized
but there's a pimple so careful okay
I'll go first Annie right in front of my
camera get down
[Laughter]
no lower yeah
okay count where's that oh my God she's
[__] doing it like
oh my God
[__] I can hear it ew
ew
ooh no why didn't I go first
this moment
well you already see it how does it look
I don't want one it's too late
that's pretty good that's pretty good
wow good job Annie ew
that's right
that's not a life skill I need to learn
Esther your turn
you got juicy crusty lips that'll be
great by the way no
there's no improvement on the lips oh my
God Annie
oh my God I don't think I can beat this
you can I'm waiting my whole life for
this moment she's nervous she's like she
might be like because she has a real
crush this is what's funny about it it's
like if it's just friends doing a gag
she literally looks like she's going to
a school dance look at her she's so
nervous
know how to make
it have you ever done it
as hard as you can
what if it gets scraped like you're
gonna look like a cutter it's gonna look
like someone slight your throat with her
[__] lip okay donut
s
yeah
oh why did you go on all your knees like
that Esther
she's riding her knee while she does it
all right she's in oh my god oh damn
I can hear it so you guys suck harder
than that suck hard suck it in I think
there's spit look at this oh my goodness
Esther
oh no I lost
another neck and let's see how long
it'll go for it may develop
yeah she's like now I can do anything oh
it's so cute so long oh no I'm not
thinking that I am oh Esther this is a
very cute and tasteful one she tastes
tacky no yours is like we're getting
down [__] yours is like I'm like grab
your head I know I should have pulled
your hair a little
um
though
I'm just thinking you guys it's hard not
to feel something really someone's on
your neck and neck is a very imaginative
zone for me yeah I turn
oh my God
it's so funny because later day is gonna
be like so why'd you call
and you'll walk in and he'll know
I can smell the dish soap in your hair
and he's going in
I hear it already go hard Annie go extra
hard
the blood is rushing to the skin now
to create a reddish look well Esther I
feel like you're enjoying this
okay by the way Carlos is like the blood
is rushing we know where it's not
rushing
wait I think you left an actual like
lump
I did that to you too I got the artery
going what
am I I'm passing away
I have a review your mouth felt so good
but this but the sucking was too hard
for me
but it is interesting like a woman's
mouth is like oh have you not made out
with girls
I have but it's been a long time it's
fun to kiss girls it's soft
exceptions are so much softer but I have
those Asian lips from Tad but Todd
sometimes goes like this like as a joke
he'll go like and I'm like no no I need
like juicy Asian lips oh geez but now we
need the kalila hickey on Esther yup and
me do you want it on your chest on your
neck wherever you want okay maybe I'll
just do it on your chest Esther's like
lower
another collidal tattoo
oh Carlos in on the chest
how are you feeling good it's kind of
it's like hurts in a good way oh man
that's good that's right mine ended up
being very long on Esther
oh my goodness wow
interesting and that's our show guys
thank you so much
all right Annie
this is a moment that we've been waiting
for mine's not very dark though I feel
like Annie's are dark they get darker as
you go okay in the middle
you've got to go you're giving it a kiss
er's just making out with her tits and
she's twerking now Donuts watching
and my husband's at work oh that's a
really cute oh you're so sad how did it
feel nobody's surprised by that but
um it felt good here I'll do your other
tip just to match that Nanny so there's
a clear way to judge
it's like cut two five minutes we're all
going down on each other here I'll just
go alone how does it feel
mommy you know
[Music]
oh my God this girl is with the fish a
lot she knows how to fish this [__]
oh like you can feel the bruise oh it's
not as bad as Esther I think
mine looks like I'm in a domestic a
domestically violent relationship
you guys get a little spray tan in there
in terms of Darkness I will say that's
not my forte
I'm more for um I'm big on the
circumference they will say it my left
head still hurts you're like oh that's
me yeah
Chesters was a delicate kiss let me see
your neck it's very long mine that was
fun
I won't lie I'm not shy
when Jesse Kirsten comes back on just
the gayest episode ever I think we
should do is that flirtier like hotter
episode than with [__] Jessica Carson
was in
okay I think we need to pick a winner it
pains me to say this but I actually
think it's pretty obvious that the
winner is Annie I agree because she
[__] went in and she sucked so hard
yeah it's so sore and they look
like
just [__] a girl who used to go go
dance professionally you can smell the
glitter yeah this is a professional
hickey
obviously one yeah all right we have a
prize oh my goodness yeah you're the
judge I think anyone yes why just
because the passion the darkness I'm for
Darkness
um the match and uh yeah I just think
she won yeah okay no one is disagreeing
so I didn't think I was gonna be judging
this considering you guys are giving
each other hickeys so it's like you guys
should judge each other we need the male
gaze okay then you win the prize is
coming from you I have a feeling No
One's Gonna be jealous of this prize
oh wait a second and you were wrong wow
guys this is actually crazy would you
have not judged a little harsher you
gave it you handed that to me think that
if there is only one skims thing for one
of us that this podcast is gonna end
today it's so cute it's it's one of
those presents too like I wouldn't have
bought it for myself which makes it even
better oh my God does that mean you're
only a little into it no it means I
really like it it's like why you get a
stylist because they grab you the thing
you wouldn't get oh damn it should have
tried harder I know
I thought I was gonna get like a dollar
store thing I have to throw out I'm
traumatized by having a mother with an
eBay drop-off score
we got a nice
song it's weird you thought Esther was
gonna win
it's like a [__] uh
like a [__]
yes oh my god oh it's almost like the
Tesla Hat's been erased
no more joke gifts we're getting real
presents now oh my God this came out of
all of our money too which is so sad I'm
gonna try harder next time that's all I
know what's our next challenge
who can come with their face not covered
wait if we who can come I might actually
win that we're not doing this we could
do not I think we should do things that
border on sexual but it's more yeah
awkwardness and disgusting as long as
I'm facing a wall I can come real fast
if we you have to blare a witch
oh my gosh she's a Blair witchcomer
oh boyla's masturbating again she's just
in the corner I can't believe I put this
headband on and didn't win
um
it is you know what it is with the boys
though it's a headband like this yeah oh
they're real it's the hairline maybe
yeah like oh you know what I'm talking
about I do because I used to date a guy
that wouldn't sometimes it's a thing I
want to say like my emotional thing
wants to be like if you date girls do
not wear a headband as a man but then my
my body and my vagina is like just never
take that out it's young it's so hot
it's very young and athletic yes anyway
okay wait so I think the next thing we
should do is we should I think there
needs to be a handcuffing situation and
maybe a feather
like a tickling competition yeah there's
a really dark documentary uh it's so
dark and it's so good when it's so dark
about it it actually has nothing to do
with tickling it has more to do with
predatory they like they hire these guys
to get tickled so they like show up and
they don't think but it's like being
tickled such a true Invasion yeah that's
why
handcuffing you to a chair and tickling
it was really what I told you guys when
I went to leatherfest and guys we got
zipped up in a body bag and just had
their balls out
if they can do it we can do it we have
to come up with something else I never
understood the idea of their skims
involved we'll come up with something
else I never understood the idea of
crotchless panties you're not into it
I'm not in no no no if I'm not wearing
underwear I don't want to wear underwear
yeah the only reason I'm wearing
underwear is to seal the hole well I'm
trying to think of where how I would
feel if I were a guy and I wouldn't be
into crotchless panties underwear is a
discharge catcher yeah it is that's all
it is guys I swear there's a reason why
I have to wear it at night when I sleep
keeps it in there tucked keeps
everything yeah it's just so the [__]
doesn't light on the snagged yeah
for those with a snaggle puss I'm not
going to say what I am but we should
sell underwear but and call them be like
discharge catchers 100 wait would you
sell underwear we should sell underwear
right now yeah oh that's our next merch
right now we use underwear oh no that's
what I meant discharge catchers will be
the first podcast would you sell your
own underwear like what's your price
it's hi me too mine's very high but I
think that with the right price
I I would absolutely sell because it's
just what's it to me I just got to make
sure it was a clean eating day you know
I don't want there to be a little extra
chocolate and I think no the higher
um if I if it's my work post workout
underwear the price is even that's what
they want yeah they want it stinky yeah
you want it stinky you had to pay it
good luck or good
good on you if you wanted stinky from
Esther because I mean that that girl
from that one show was not 90 Day Fiance
but yeah yeah the fart girl should we
sell our farts I cannot produce that
much as much as she did oh my God she's
such a brag I can't fart no no [__]
[__] I can't grow [__] hair or fart
did you know how much farts she was
selling it got so bad that she had to go
to the ER because she thought she was
having a heart attack but was she taking
such apartment yeah she was eating beans
she was eating everything that would
cause flatulence and I cannot do that I
just love that she had like probably a
boyfriend with her that was just like
she is bringing in a lot of money but uh
yeah she's bringing like 100k like a
month right just on her farts should we
get a should we get a gauge for what our
dirt what a dirty panty would go for yes
what would you guys pay and this is dead
serious no wait for the right price
you're getting them yeah because it's
like they're just gonna go in the wash I
might as well just mail them to you or
in the trash I'm pretty rich now
laughs
why send in the trash I mean it is
something that no other podcast none of
the male comedy podcasts can do well
they're too busy dming us
they should just watch the show oh by
the way I saw Theo last night and I saw
Tim Dylan and I go Theo you should
probably so should you and then Theo's
like we should do it together that'd be
fun Tim Dylan and Theo oh I would love
both of them on thank you for telling
them we need to get them on here you
know what my dream would be if I would
have Tim Dillon be my Auctioneer for my
dirty panties oh yeah we can have them
on the Dirty Dancing because he'll be
really disgusted do a live show right do
a live stream show one day of all of us
and we do a live auction should we call
him right now and ask him if he would do
that hello hey
I have a question for you
are you available to answer we're on my
podcast
I'm answering right now what's going on
okay so we're on the podcast yeah we're
on the podcast we were wondering if you
would we're trying to see how much
underwear how much money we could get
for our dirty underwear we're wondering
if you would be the auctioneer for that
who you and who Esther and kalila
Esters has already come pre-dirtied Lila
and I would have to just choose to not
bathe
Auctioneer like like
like who's like
like I don't understand like like a
Sotheby's auction yes like I said yeah
exactly like a southern Sotheby's
auction the same prices too we want it
to be like really
we want to make Tim Dylan patreon money
off of underwear
it's literally the rate for my for any
of my time right now it's 75 000 oh
we've gone down 5 000.
yeah no it's 75 and you ladies I like
I'll do it for like 60 you know we could
be uh be reasonable we're expecting
large numbers so that's not out of the
question
it's something I'm open to we love it
also what does he think Tim what do you
think of us selling our dirty underwear
I mean I find all women repulsive
is a huge market for things like that
I've done so much in my life to not ever
do these things but you know if it's for
the podcast
yeah I mean you got to do what you got
to do you know you gotta do what you got
that makes it sound really sad Tim what
do you think of us
do you think we're pathetics that we
want to sell our underwear
no I I don't think so at all I think
it's empowering
you know what I'm seeing in Esther's
eyes she wants you to like really yell
at her Esther wants you to come in here
and really demean her she's a six six
Tim will you degrade me
evil you can tell you've only met her
twice she's evil nice girl
I don't know
Oh no you're breaking up I bet it was
such a good idea you might have said
something mean what did he say we can't
hear you but um I want to thank you for
the good time last night
I know that's so funny oh the Hill's The
Dead Zone that's where rich people you
know what's so weird it's like just sign
a do not resuscitate too if you live in
the Hills like yeah an ambulance ain't
getting up there landline that's all you
need to land you're gonna die yeah they
can't get up those little those little
streets yeah I can't believe you just
said that I'm doing
um for sleepover byester I'm doing
hoodies that say do not resuscitate oh I
can't believe you just that's a good
idea the NR I like how you're like I
gotta start making them funny
this is good this is happening in your
whole life you're going maybe I'll try
being funny you've been coasting on
trying really hard not to be funny and
you're doing it in stand up you're doing
it in your merch I love it do not
resuscitate so good I can't believe you
just said that what did we learn today
we learned that Tim Dylan is our
Sotheby's Auctioneer wow he's in he's
the perfect one because he's repulsed by
our dirty underwear and then you know
what he can also be very very specific
in the description
like you know right along the gooch line
we have a mysterious white spot here
in the underwear there ain't gonna be
nothing white in my undies
we all have new life skills Annie's the
biggest [__] in terms of sucking on
necks for fesh and I'm so cute and she
got skims for it which she deserves but
I'm jealous
and anything else Tim Dylan and theoson
are going to be on this podcast that's
I'm manifesting save your pretty pennies
boys or pennies are coming I want to
have Mark onto I want to do I want to
have a uh Zinger off with Mark Norman
love it let's do it we'll see you guys
next week and also
2022 goals we want to get to 200k
subscribers so please subscribe to this
channel if you haven't yet within the
month we want this in the month we want
to show the men in comedy that our dirty
panties are more important than their
jokes
[__] subscribe
[Music]